hey everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
the Ingram angle thank you for being
with us tonight
Biden's deadly trust deficit that is the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now we already know Washington is
running Sky High trade and budget
deficits but we have another deficit
that now has the potential to turn
deadly
a trust deficit
Noah knocked on my door I looked 50 feet
from the police station why didn't
Sirens go on like a tornado warning or
something that didn't happen
[Music]
[Applause]
this is heartbreaking the
administration's response to this
derailment has been abysmal Biden's EPA
administrator finally showed up in Ohio
today that was only because of the
public outcry and mounting political
Fallout
and today there was yet another
derailment of a train carrying hazardous
materials this time just outside of
Detroit
is it just me or does it seem like there
have been a lot of train derailments
lately
or are we supposed to believe this is
all part of The New Normal
of course this is not normal it is
totally unacceptable
until we at Fox and a handful of other
journalists started to demand answers
the Biden teams seemed to be fairly
unfazed by all of this
so when they finally do speak out under
political pressure they have zero
credibility
they've Left Behind such a trail of lies
on all subjects that I wasn't surprised
when Gallup found that Americans now
think the government is the biggest
problem facing the United States
the East Palestine trained derailment is
just the latest example of how far
things have fallen
because Biden staffed his cabinet with
activists and not men and women of
experience and talent
we've had disaster after disaster
now when DHS HHS the Department of
Education and of course the Department
of Transportation faced a crisis
there's just no one at the top who can
step up to give the president Sound
Advice we know he's not running anything
and with these multiple derailments
there's no one of any stature who can
stand before the public explain the
facts very clearly
and take questions
there is no one who can calm the
Public's fraying nerves
this was leave it to Pete bootage's idea
of how to take charge after the Ohio
nightmare too afraid to show up there he
tweeted
we're constrained by law on some areas
of rail regulation like the breaking
rule withdrawn by the Trump
Administration in 2018 because of a law
passed by Congress in 2015. but we're
using the powers we do have to keep
people safe oh really
fact check on Mr Rhodes Scholar
now the rule that Trump repealed in 20
in
2018 I think it was related to trains
carrying crude oil
which was not the case here okay
and plus if this was such a dangerous
deregulatory move
why didn't we ever hear Pete talk about
it before why didn't he do something
about it
week week that's why
when blaming a president who hasn't been
in office for two years didn't work he
tried to downplay the entire thing
while this uh horrible situation has
gotten a particularly high amount of
attention there are roughly 1 000 cases
a year of a train derailing
well here's a novel idea
why don't you stop preening before the
cameras about Transportation equity and
start doing your job
stop blaming other people show up though
and face the music when people are
suffering and scared because of
something like toxic derailments
has gotten some presses under that he
waited too long to respond and then he's
his seemed to be fixated on trying to
deflect the lame to the previous
administration so does the president is
he satisfied with the with the
government's response to this derailment
I can answer that very quickly and very
uh with quick with confidence from here
that we do have absolute confidence in
in mayor Pete and it's like I always say
that secretary uh Buddha judge
that's right we think of him as mayor
Pete too or maybe just paternity Pete
the man should never have been put in
this position in the first place and
should be fired immediately
any cabinet official or senior staff
member who takes extended fraternity
leave while our supply chains are
breaking down
by definition that person is unserious
now this is what happens when you
prioritize diversity and Equity over
competence and experience
America just ends up with a cabinet
filled with nincompoops radicals who
point fingers instead of solving
problems
and unfortunately for Ohio the results
may be deadly and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else